[Music]
all right
talk about a quinky dink in this story
there were these two drivers driving the
same car no no teacher and uh
two cars the first person they had just
stolen
a person's toyota land cruiser okay oh i
like that car
that's a good car to steal so then a few
minutes after it was stolen
it was spotted through like driving
through town uh
by police so then police started trying
to chase this car
down and he was trying to elude the
police
trying to get away so as he was trying
to get away this fool he crashes into
a buick regal
and it turns out that that car was also
stolen driven by this woman
oh [ __ ] two stolen cars get into
accident exactly so the buick was stolen
reported stolen
three weeks ago and so luckily for this
crash
they were both caught double case solved
also pretty much the cops just got
super lucky super lucky that's why i
said talk about it
she's kind of she's like i look cute in
this huh this is how they fall in love
this is the beginning of their love
story
did you steal the car like i stole the
car
so she was a buick there's a toyota land
cruiser yeah land cruiser
can we see the accident no i don't think
that'd be cool if the car hit in the
shape of a heart tooth
and they're two red cars
and then all the gasoline like started
spilling out and then it caught on fire
but it was a perfect heart
yeah that's beautiful helicopters were
like oh my god look at this
so it turns out that kristen the girl uh
she was found to be under the influence
of i don't know what
but drunk in love
[Music]
intoxicants that's it intoxication
that's a nice heartbeat thank you
wait what the [ __ ] oh there you go ow
thank you how do you do that oh [ __ ]
i don't think i'm doing it right one of
my fingers won't work wait
no my nails don't look good take your
index finger
and you curl them okay and then your
middle finger
straighten them i can't train one one oh
no i can't do it
i think i did it but it's upside down i
can't no yours is illuminati
you're like a really bad illuminati i
made a smaller heart
not bad what about this there it is guys
the airbnb logo
i think i got it guys perfect
there's this one there's this one this
is this one
is this one damn that's what's going on
all that stuff what's this one
that's the kpop one when i found out
about this i'm like how
[ __ ] cute this one's damn it but it's
so cute this isn't just like a little
tiny heart this is like essentially your
heart like
like these are like supposed to be your
veins for you this is your aorta
cute it's like it's so this whole this
also means oh [ __ ] you modify
your whole heart and that like i forgot
which one but once like your aorta and
the other one's the
pulmonary yeah yeah and then this is the
beating heart or this is like
your penis is this peak yeah or the
world's smallest violin
world's small adorable but yeah
i don't know i would love to see if they
end up dating yeah honestly if this
doesn't turn into a perfect love story
this story is beyonce type they follow
with cameras and everything in jail
that'd be pretty cool that'd be cool
they have the same prosecutor who's also
the person who like officiates them
if you go to jail for a crime you should
be giving up your rights to be filmed
for
entertainment tv oh nothing else
everything else should be stayed
well wouldn't that fall under like the
like them working and it's like bad
yeah all of a sudden they're a union
actor now well yeah you do all that
stuff they probably get better
and think and then when they come out
they have like a career and to get them
off the streets
so if you're in jail you'll also get
paid then you get your day rate yeah
yeah you get your
your like your top ramen no yeah you get
like meals yeah
so you don't get a day rate yeah so then
every celebrity then in the future
is a previous convict but what if they
unionized an ex-convict
a lot of them huh but what if they
unionize no that's what we're saying
they're gonna be
unionized already if they're gonna isn't
that just called the prison gang
no do you guys remember we're locked up
abroad kind of
show you remember that uh movie it was
like
race like death race or some [ __ ] where
they're like
uh bruce i think bruce willis was one of
them or whatever but oh yeah
they're like uh inmates and then they
have to race
and they kill each other shoot guns out
the car it's kind of like
a modern day butler was in that
[Music]
no that's gamer but i know what you're
talking about death race was wasn't that
jason statham
it was one of those it was one yeah i
think it was i think it was satan yeah
one of those baldwins yeah it was a bad
guy jason statham
that there stab them and hit that black
car with like the bulletproof on it
yeah yeah yeah yeah there might have
been a shitty what if it's like that
like
kind of like hunger gamesy but nobody
dies um
dude would you be down then that's more
like gamer that's more like gamer though
because those are convicts in gamer it's
like you're a convert yeah so instead of
death then
it's just about love and reality tv
but that means you're assuming that
there's co-ed prisons like that right
that these gamers would be a part of
there's already a reality tv show called
locked up
it's not about locked in love yeah it's
not locked at all we should be called
locked in love that's a dope ass show
what if they like don't fall in love do
they just like have to like shank each
other that's even
more drama that's so weird is it like
the bachelor or 98 fiancee but then it's
like
for inmates yeah i like it inmates or
soul mates or cellmates oh
cell mates that's a good one cell mates
but what's the story well you know love
is blind the whole point is
the the journey is supposed to be okay
let's take the superficial
physical out of it see if i could fall
in love with someone and then look at
the person they are right why is reality
tv so obsessed with people falling in
love
because it's primal yeah i mean so are
other things oh yeah i mean that's like
food that's like food
food stuff you can find love through it
and then that's why there's also just
straight porno
so when it gets farther everybody wants
to see the foreplay though
but people want to see either love or
they want to see food or they want to
see
drama yeah like a drama and people want
to see losers that are worse than them
what about fashion there is fashion
reality i know but i'm saying
he's leaving all the primal like food
fight or what was it
fashion's primal cat no that that was my
joke but i know like that
it's probably drama what's the drama
we're supposed to laugh the bad one it
was a bad one
it was a bad job for tvs and movies like
depending on who's producing those
things
like because they have that money to
make this show or movie happen
and if they feel like it's not going to
be enough to sell like
oh where's the romance we need some
romance in there just to attract a
certain audience to go
they're always that's very pg what they
really mean is we need
nipples in this cells right
i don't know 98 a fiance i wouldn't want
to see most of them naked
most like 99 of the characters naked
i just love the drama is so [ __ ] good
have you guys seen too hot to handle
that sounds familiar but i haven't seen
it i only saw one episode
but i can understand why it would be
hilariously addicting why
uh they're set on this like or i guess
the premise is they
they're all these like really hot people
they get put on this island
oh they can't [ __ ] because they're sex
addicts yeah yes they all love sex yeah
but if you don't [ __ ]
you win like a million dollars or
something or a hundred thousand dollars
are they really sexy yeah they're like
all
well they all say they love sex and
they're all like you know
very attractive type people they put on
but they don't know that that's the game
they once they get there they get
introduced like that but obviously
they get to there there's like speed
dating there's a bunch of activities
that
bring them really close there's like
truth or dares skinny dipping
yeah there's lots of that stuff but you
just cannot you know
dude can you masturbate
yeah i don't know i don't i don't know
can you lose over and over again on the
show no
we lost last night and we lost again and
we just get kicked out
oh usually there's a cash come survivor
come survivor so we gotta do that but
for like cellmates
no not not saying they can't
but maybe it's like something else you
know like like bart said there's gotta
be a story
same yeah what's the journey well i
don't know we're talking about these two
people that actually
got a car accident you know what i mean
i thought i thought it would be like
how would they continue their love by
being locked up
in like lady jail and mail jail and then
they get their conjugal visits
and then oh so like maybe the whole
episode is like how well they like
dig through with the spoon to like
communicate their love to the person and
like send a little they do it in real
presence where they literally send notes
and they flush the toilet yeah they
empty the toilet so they can communicate
because through the piping that's how
they do when they talk to the guys and
girls
and they fall in love with through
yelling into a toilet
facilities no son isn't the same for
toys but it's it's blocking the one
that's
uh galen's in right now it's not all
female
it's well they're separated but they're
separated yeah different
rooms different halls you could see that
what are you talking about people
yelling through toilets
they literally back up the toilet for
communication
inmates it was it's like on a show that
they they're uh i'll
see where they do that though yeah so
they scoop out the water until it's
empty right
um and then they make sure they leave it
bang so they know they're they're doing
it
they yell through it and they're like oh
this person wants to talk to this person
so they're yelling into the toilets and
it's coming out the other end like
you know when you used to do the
telephone with the string yeah it's kind
of like that but it actually works
or they send stuff downstream too yeah
they have like a long one
balloon i don't know like [ __ ] heroin
or something they want to send it to the
home they put in the
well they put like twinkies and they
give it like make sure that girl gets it
and then they fall in love
and literally have relationships with
never mind it's like a really extreme
version
of being in in like back in elementary
school you're sending notes to your
friend
or you're passing it to your home to
your homie to your homie yeah and then
they're like
do you like fred because fred told me he
likes you yeah
all right and then you run over and
you're like fred she likes you all right
can you tell her this all right and then
you [ __ ] run
like everyone had to do that for their
friends that's how i got my first
boyfriend in fourth grade
no but that's how they do it everyone
had to do that for like each other they
literally passed notes and they're like
hey this person likes this person and
then this person
yes or no yeah exactly and they'll give
it to like the cafeteria worker that's
one of the inmates and sometimes then
they have to meet the girl
i wonder how kids are doing it this
these days text kids or
prison people because i'm in a different
realm right now i was thinking prison or
hey tell baby joker i like him yeah and
they [ __ ] tell baby joker so they
pass notes baby joker's like a huge
person yeah yeah
killer likes you i saw this guys i saw
this one episode where
they fell in love and then he saw her
and was like oh [ __ ] but they were tired
for months
and then he didn't like it yeah he's
like
me like in jail yeah but he enjoyed her
personality
yeah she probably was imagining her to
be way hotter that's his fault and then
he saw it he's like
oh that's not what i imagined your voice
was so nice
that's so good but i can understand
because i mean have you been catfished
catfished no are you sure how would you
know
looks are important yeah my roommate got
catfished the other day
what the other day of the week what
happened it was like just talking to
this hot girl then she comes over and
she looks nothing like she did on the
photos
and then so they're we got catfish
they're our worst catfishes
they're just not that same person yeah
i've been catfished before
not the same person that i saw in the
picture or if it was it's like an
amazing photoshop
oh there are definitely lots of other
catfishes where it's like different
genders and stuff you know whoa
oh well that's just the trap sometimes
it's kind of sad because it's like well
that is that person
it was just a long time ago it was a
really great angle it was really good
makeup day or whatever it was and it's
really good photoshop too not really
trying to fake who they are that's true
there are some complete fakes
yeah like you get a picture of a blonde
white girl and then you show up
and it's like an asian girl and you're
like what happened
[Music]
catfish
[Music]
you